are you existing applications holding
you back find out how you can use add
those to modernize your existing
applications and accelerate performance
I am priyanka and welcome to you and
those 101 in many organizations legacy
applications can hold back business
initiatives while new applications are
being developed using cloud native
technologies most existing applications
are still large monolithic apps that run
on proprietary application servers
incurring high licensing costs slow
release cycles and vendor lock-in the
lion's share of existing apps in
enterprises are written in Java and
according to a recent study 80% of
companies will continue to leverage past
investments in Java apps 40% of
companies will modify legacy Java apps
for cloud migration and 79% will
modernize the Java apps with cloud
native technologies like containers and
kubernetes organizations looking to
modernize a java application typically
have two goals in mind one to adopt
modern development frameworks and
architectures and to move to containers
and adopt DevOps practices to achieve
these goals and those offers a solid
path to modernize your tower
applications to realize immediate
operational cost savings reduce
dependencies on higher cost proprietary
software and increase software delivery
speed we see Enterprise Java
applications fall in one of the three
categories and each requires that you
take a unique approach to modernization
first category applications using modern
frameworks these are newer apps written
on modern Java frameworks like spring
boot the next step for these
applications is to take advantage of
Google cloud managed services spring
cloud GCP lets your developers easily
adopt Google cloud services build tools
like jib and cloud native built backs
provide an easy way to containerize
these applications using well-known
developer build tools like maven and
gradall once containerized you can
manage these applications with anthos
the second category is commercial
off-the-shelf applet
patience these don't have the source
code for these types of applications my
great fir anthos allows you to move VMs
from on-premise data centers to either
VMs running in Google Cloud or to
containers running on anthos GAE a cloud
agnostic implementation of GAE that runs
in multiple environments this lets you
quickly adopt a modern platform whether
on Prem or in the cloud and especially
useful if you have a large number of
applications as they can be migrated
with minimal effort third category
applications running on proprietary
servers these are your Java applications
developed in-house using older
frameworks and often running on
commercial proprietary application
servers Google cloud provides a two-step
process for modernizing these
applications first use migrate ver
anthos to quickly migrate existing
applications running in VMs to
containers on add those you can also
migrate off of commercial app servers to
open source app servers to reduce or
eliminate licensing costs second
refactor and rewrite migrated
applications to use modern frameworks
like spring boot and spring cloud GCP
and move to a micro service development
model Java app modernization journey
with anthos leads to tremendous cost
savings but onboarding the Java app to
containers you see a 37% total cost of
ownership savings instantaneously then
by automating with software pipeline and
refactoring you can see an additional
78% savings there you have it
with anthos you can modernize your
existing Java applications and
accelerate performance ready to start
your modernization journey schedule an
application assessment workshop with
your Google team and for more anthos
content don't forget to subscribe and
check out the entire and those 101
playlist
[Music]